[Music]
welcome back to the next episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hi we have a hot topic
today
yes let's get right into it i'll open
with the word of prayer
okay our heavenly father thank you very
much for bringing us again together
we ask a blessing on the discussion we
ask the in
working of the holy spirit to enlighten
us and
to make our minds think upon the things
that you want us to think in jesus name
amen amen
yes this is sometimes a controversial
subject it's been a controversial
subject
from the beginning yeah because we have
two parties in the world
and people think we have hundreds of
parties there are only two
so you've come from
the education world
so this must be something that really
has an impact on your life absolutely
this is
uh probably the most important topic
and i have been
on both sides of this argument now
and well we'll have to talk about
the issues and then we'll see
how this all comes together it's a
it's a historic problem and it will be
a end-time culminative
problem we're talking today about
a new education there's a lot of talk
about a new education
actual fact the bible already says
there's nothing new under the sun
i think what they are talking about is a
consolidated
education which they will call a new
education
which happens to be the old education
which finally
has arrived at the point of universal
acceptance okay yeah and it also stems
from
the pope where he wanted to have this
re-education seminar seminar get
together
and then the covet 19 put that on hold
in like
october and then they had uh virtual
get together yes well we need to talk
about this
i believe that this is one of the most
important topics for our time
this is the topic that will finally
determine the outcome of all choices
it's very important that we talk about
it
so let's jump right into it thank you
this is the vatican news from 15 october
and the pope calls for a global compact
on
education bears in itself a seed of hope
i of course beg to differ but that's
just the nature of things
so let's see why we beg to differ it's
one thing to say that you differ but you
need to
qualify when you want to say something
like that
so pope francis relaunches the global
compact on education on thursday with a
video message
during a virtual event at rome's
pontifical
lateran university let's make that quite
clear that's the jesuit
holy grail right
in this situation the pope called for a
new cultural
and development model that respects and
protects human dignity
while creating a global interdependence
to bring communities and people together
to care for our common home and to
foster
peace that's a very loaded statement
it has everything in it from communities
to his encyclical on the environment his
encyclical
on fraternity all of these issues
education the pope said is meant to be
transformative in what direction
it should present a hope that can
shatter the determinism
and fatalism of selfishness of the
strong
it should shatter the conformism of the
weak
and the ideology of the utopians as the
only way forward
the pope pointed out that education
is a natural antidote to the
individualistic
culture that at times degenerates into a
true
cult of the self and the primacy
of indifference he has a thing about
individualism because the catholic
church throughout history
wanted conformity to its will
and any individualist who was a free
thinker was an
enemy of the church and to this day
they haven't changed their stance not at
all
this of course would get rid of all free
thinkers
there would be no huss there would be
no martin luther there would be no john
knox there would be
no latimer there would be no cranmer
none of them would exist there would be
no wesley
there would be nobody who thinks
differently
to the rest of society
the commitment of every level of society
said is needed for
a renewed kind of education that is not
tempted to look the other way and thus
favor grave
social injustices violations of
rights terrible forms of poverty and the
waste of human lives
this is interesting this is the richest
organization in the history of humanity
but it doesn't seem to bother
itself with these issues and yes they
have a lot of social work that they do
but not out of their coffers it has to
come from donations from outside
yeah let's listen to what he had to say
this is his speech
concerning this issue
responsibility
individualistica
well he's made it quite clear that
individualism
is his enemy yes on
every level whether it be cultural or
otherwise
every level individualism is the enemy
of the church and the enemy of the
community
and so we have to be uniform
i mean if you take the jesuit reductions
in south america where they used the
indian labor
and organized them into reductions which
became the model for communism
then you have this kind of fruit
of that kind of thinking everybody is
the same
and nothing but total misery because it
curtails your freedom now
let's just look at this history and see
where all of this came from and why
there is this clash
of thinking here's an interesting
article
that appeared in
the university of arizona documents
and this document is about martin luther
who was an
advocate for education reform
so martin luther asked for a new
education
yeah interesting right it is interesting
yes so what was wrong with the old
education
and let's just make it quite clear who
ran the old
education correct the catholic church
so martin luther advocated for a new
education now this article was written
in 2017
and it says in his quest to help
christians read and
understand scripture for themselves
luther favored compulsory education
for all his views on education will be
discussed as part of the april 11 early
book lecture
series at the university of arizona
in the article it says during a time
when school often was limited to the
sons of the wealthy
luther argued for compulsory education
for
all his main reason education was
necessary so that
christians could read and understand
scripture for themselves
that was the solo scripture basis right
that's the whole reason that he wanted
compulsory education for and he wanted
literacy forms
so that people could understand their
bibles correct
luther was determined to wrestle control
of the schools from the roman catholic
church
so he had a problem with them right
one of the reasons luther is approaching
the city fathers
is he wants the primary responsibility
for
education to be grasped by those men
and taken away from the ecclesiastics in
the town now all the schools
in those days were run by the church
and historically the universities of the
world
were all church institutions
and this is the document that he wrote
to the rulers this is an original which
this university by the way
bought a copy of and
it states quite clearly what his views
on education was it's a very
famous document
this is one of the the sentences that
martin luther wrote
to the rulers of the time my dear sirs
if we have to spend such large sums
every year
on guns roads bridges dams and countless
similar items to ensure the temporal
peace and prosperity of a city
why should not much more be devoted to
the poor neglected youth
a city's best and greatest welfare
safety and strength consists
rather in its having many able learned
wise honorable and well-educated
citizens
luther also espoused a classical
education
so why did you want all of this as well
so that people had a broad view and that
could understand the issues
first introduced during the renaissance
and that included
history languages
such as greek hebrew and latin believing
such a broad
education would aid in the study of the
bible
now in our own denomination we have
certain guidelines as well which had
they been followed to the letter would
have blessed
beyond our wildest dreams
and it has been suggested that what was
taught in the schools of the prophets
should also be the basis for education
and there was sacred history so history
is
very important there was sacred music
there was prophecy there was the study
of the bible
and then there were practical issues
such as
gardening how to do farming sustaining
education in terms of
practical issues that was the education
that was supposed to be there
but unfortunately that is not what has
happened
now here's another publication that i
found very interesting
this comes from teach diligently
resources for christian
education it also gives the views of
martin luther on
education reformation so a new
education
reforming the universities luther wrote
the universities need a sound
and thorough reformation
loose living is practiced there little
is taught of the holy scriptures all the
christian
faith the blind pagan teacher
aristotle is of more consequence than
christ do we have a similar situation in
the world today
yes absolutely absolutely
but there are still remnants here and
there of people
that believe what martin luther said so
you still have some church schools that
try
in spite of the flood of opposite
education to try and cope
but of course curricula are so designed
that even if you are yes in a
school of private education you still
have to conform to certain norms in
order to get into mainstream education
and to be
acknowledged correct and when you get to
mainstream
education well then you get into the
secular universities
which by the way were not secular in the
beginning
yes but even then they were started by
the roman catholic system
reforming the universities luther argued
that the universities needed reform
because he knew the impact they have on
future generations
universities shape and mold future
leaders
including christian leaders and he said
for christian youth
and those of our upper classes with whom
abides the future of christianity
will be taught and trained in the
universities
in my view no work more worthy of the
pope and the emperor could be carried
out than a
true reformation of the universities
on the other hand nothing could be more
wicked
or serve the devil better than
unreformed
universities in actual fact he was
saying
that the universities served the devil
and were wicked yeah that's what he was
saying
they needed a reformation
the bible in education luther did not
limit his comments to the university
as he believed the bible ought to be
central to
all education now is that acceptable in
the world today
no not at all absolutely not
luther knew the obligation christian
parents have to train their children in
the faith and this begins in the lower
levels of education
he wrote above all the most important
and most
usual teaching in both the universities
and the lower schools
ought to be concerned with the holy
scriptures
oh how unwisely we deal with our poor
young
folk whom we are commanded to train
and instruct
but we shall have to give a serious
account of our stewardship and explain
why we have not set the word of god
before them
we fail to notice the present pitiful
distress of the young people
though they live in the midst of a
christian world they
faint and perish in misery because they
lack the gospel in which we should be
training and
exercising them all the time
that is something that doesn't exist in
the world today no
it's actually sad if you come to think
of it after this
that he wrote in the reformation days
yes that chris even though they were
christian universities and schools and
everything
they eventually moved over back to
basically secular system
now who is responsible we'll have to
look at that
towards the end of luther's essay we
read his classic line
on education and his advice would be
well heeded by parents today
he writes but i would not advise anyone
to send his son to a place where the
holy scriptures do not come
first well where can you send your
children then
nowhere no way how many parents have
sent
believing children to secular
universities
only to get them back as
atheists and infidels
every institution where the word of god
is not
taught regularly must fail
that is why we observe the kind of
people who are now
and will continue to be in the
universities
i greatly fear that the universities are
but wide
open gates leading to hell
as they are not diligent in training and
impressing the holy scriptures on young
students
my wife's grandmother
cried many many tears because her
children were all highly educated and
became professors at
universities but they all became
atheists
and so what martin luther said
here is absolutely true
now i did not become an atheist when i
went to the university because i already
was one yeah
and why was i an atheist why because of
the education
because of the education i received at
school
and the education at school and
particularly the education i received in
religious instruction
by through the roman catholic system
i made sure that i was an atheist even
by the time i got to the university
fascinating and then the author of this
article
is zachary garris let me just say who he
is zachary garris is an attorney and
author he holds a master of divinity
from the reformed theological
seminary jackson missouri and a juris
doctor
from wayne state university law school
he is
licensed to preach in the presbyterian
church in america
and he has taught high school and sunday
school courses on ancient history
early church history medieval history
logic
bible systematic theology covenant
theology apologetics and worldview
so he's a well-educated man and his
conclusion
is we are witnessing exactly what luther
warned against
failed institutions
the majority of our schools and
universities have failed to train
students in the wisdom of christ and
they have instead trained students in a
progressive and
anti-christian world view it is no
stretch to say that our schools and
universities are responsible for
much of the moral chaos of our day
they have opened the gates to hell and
only the grace of god can overcome them
this is a very modern document yeah and
the conclusion is the same
as was reached by martin luther 500
years ago
now i've come through this training and
education
it's interesting that martin luther was
for educating all classes
even girls and that was a no-no in those
days
and he himself had i think it was three
daughters
one died at birth one died when she was
13 years old
but he advocated for schools and he
started the school
in wittenberg where the girls could
attend
so that they could be educated and could
understand and read and understand these
things
this was the kind of education that
protestantism brought to the world yes
and the last vestiges of this education
must now be destroyed
here's another fascinating article it
comes from
steemit the war against books to set up
learning against
learning is a jesuit strategy
the phrase learning against learning
comes from
cardinal thomas woolsey
addressing the pope about the dangers of
the printing press
to the church's control
how can you say that the printing press
is a danger to the church in other words
knowledge true knowledge is a danger
to the church
the goal of the catholic church became
to start a war
against books
as d israeli put it in the last
chapter war against books in his book
amenities of literature from 1841
this is also referring to the gutenberg
press that was
developed right in the reformation
absolutely it was the
enemy of the papers why
because it put the word of god into
people's hands
and the literature that went along with
it the writings of martin luther for
example
it is stressed to ignazius lyola's rules
for jesuits
that was the father of the jesuit order
right
but there were three founders actually
it was ignazius lyola he was the founder
then there was peter faba who was the
german
co-founder of the jesuits and he is the
one who actually
brought the philosophy of learning uh
to this illustrious group and then there
was francis xavier yeah
now he was the one that lived the
shortest
and faba was really the one that
drove the philosophy but uh
ignacio is lyola he's the one who had
the visions and he created the
the exercises so the grand rule of the
order
is to make thinking conform with the
catholic church
elaborated in 18 specific rules of which
rule number 13
says the 13th and finally that we
may be all together of the same mind
and in conformity with the church
herself
no individualistic thinking interesting
if she shall have defined anything to be
black
which is to our eyes appears to be white
we ought in like manner to pronounce it
to be white
autograph the 13th that we may in all
things attain
the truth that we may not er in
anything we ought ever to hold it
as a fixed principle that what i see
white
i believe to be black
if the hierarchical church so define it
to be that's the spiritual of
exercises of ignazious life i cannot
bring myself to say
saint but it says there saint 15
41 unbelievable
no no that's really unbelievable you
don't have any thoughts of yourself so
sorry
if you see something is white and the
church says it's black
isn't this just just what the pub said
in other words didn't we just listen to
his speech
yep if you don't agree with them
you have no right there's no room for
you there's no room for you
okay he writes
further in this article the dastardly
bertrand russell explains this strategy
was embraced
by johann fichter who laid it down that
education should aim at destroying free
will
and that the social psychologists of the
future will have a number of classes of
school children
on whom they will try different methods
of producing an
unshakable conviction that snow is black
is there a reference there yes to what
lyola said
yep the blame were the culprit for
setting up
learning against learning and waging a
war on
books are ignazius lyola
thomas woolsey johann fichter
and bertrand russell
isaac the israeli deserves credit for
fighting against the jesuits and here
are
the sources for the document
this is not a conspiracy this is
a fact of history and
so many people argue and fight against
it
because they are part of the very
institutions which
practice lyola's instructions
on the minds of young people
in our universities now is it true
that our universities do this now
i have some experience in this i was
at one of the largest universities in
our country
where i taught and i was an atheist
and i taught evolution and there was a
theology department in that university
but it could not
counteract what the evolutionists were
saying
and to this day when you switch on the
radio they have programs
where my ex-colleagues are proclaiming
the virtues of evolution and the
ignorance and stupidity of those who
believe the bible
i attended a interesting
[Music]
meeting once where one of the
high channels in the world that is one
of the
occult channels informed me
that the universities were being
instructed in occultism by these
very occultists and we're talking now
about the
theological seminaries and if you attend
those schools of theology in the world
today
you lea you read and learn about
what all the learned men have said about
religion
and carl bart becomes more important
than the word of god
there is in most of the seminaries no
real study of the word of god
nobody comes out of those universities
knowing what the book of daniel is all
about
the reformers knew yeah but the
so-called reformed seminaries don't
teach it
they have no clue as to what the book of
revelation is about
or what revelation 13 is about they
should at least know what the reformers
taught
but they don't they learn what
infidels have said and that becomes the
norm
now at one stage i was actually
persuaded
that i should get a degree in theology
because it seems to be a mindset of the
people
that if you do not have a degree in
theology
then you better refrain from any
theological issue
yes have you come across that yes
yes and i was often
confronted with this kind of thinking it
sounds a little bit to me and when i was
confronted with
it i heard almost the pharisees
shouting there yes who is this man who
has not known letters
so they condemned the disciples they
condemned john they condemned
jesus himself right so i had one stage
decided i'm going to
thwart these these intellectuals
at the colleges and universities
and get a degree in theology
and i went to the university where i was
teaching at the time
and i went to the theological seminary
which was protestant and said i want to
enroll
for a degree in theology what must i do
well i was professor at that stage and i
had you know phd
in in science
and so the man said to me well well
that's very fascinating you know you
have so many degrees already
what we need to do is to give you a
bridging course
you'll write an exam and then you'll go
straight into a masters and then later
into a doctoral thesis
and i said well that's wonderful let's
do that and he said well
you can start the thesis immediately if
you want to
have you any topic in mind
well i thought to myself you know
how am i going to do this quickly
so i said well can't i do a thesis on
genesis versus modern scientific
thinking
he nearly had a heart failure and said
no no no
that won't do because we will not align
ourselves with
anything that is contrary to the
evolutionary paradigm
so i said well so a thesis where you
constructively compare the scriptural
story with the scientific knowledge of
the day
and even if it should support some of
the scriptural issues would not be
satisfactory and he said
absolutely not we will not make fools of
ourselves
so i said okay that's fine so we'll
leave that topic
now at that stage i was very interested
in
the new age movement and all of the
philosophies of these
self-proclaimed messiahs and also
the appearances of these messiahs which
were all contrary to scripture
so i suggested a thesis on
the biblical criteria for the biblical
messiah
versus the messiahs in the world out
there which is a very broad
field and he looked at me
with this glossy look
and he said to me which
biblical messiah are you referring to
okay now this is a protestant theologian
speaking right
and i looked at him and i asked him
is there more than one
and he said oh yes the bible is all
allegories
everybody is a messiah or a potential
messiah
so i said to him very well i will think
about it
and i left it at that realizing that
argument
was absolutely not achieving anything
and i got back to my office and i
thought to myself well if this is the
education that the theologians have
then they're welcome to it i will be
satisfied with my
scientific knowledge and whatever i can
glean
out of the writings of the word of god
amen and those that support it but that
was as far as it went in the meantime of
course i
i do have a degree in theology but uh
that's well you actually have uh
honorary doctorate
that's right but that's another story
let's not leave it
let's not go there so the blameworthy
culprits
are ignazius lyola thomas woolsey
johann victor and bertrand russell
this is very interesting
but let's get to a modern time we've
compared now
what the ancient conflict in education
was
this is now our illustrious
president of france who of course has
jesuit education
right yes and he's a friend of
the pope very very much son
and this is catholic family france moves
to ban
homeschooling in 2021.
now what is there in homeschooling that
is so undesirable
it's the fact that people can educate
their children
in ways that might be contrary to the
wishes
of some of these illustrious gentlemen
right
yes when the when the syllabus
teaches something the parent or any
computer can correct and say okay
this is what's being taught here but
this is not the truth
or here's an alternative here's an
alternative
so french president emmanuel macron
announced on friday morning that he
intends to outlaw homeschooling for all
children
except those who have a health condition
that would justify
staying away from school he also intends
to step up control
on private independent schools that
receive no public funds
that's interesting you see if you
receive public funds then you are
subject to the government
yes and you have to make sure that that
curriculum is taught
so anybody who has any mind of his own
there
will have to be curtailed right
in particular through inspections on the
curricular thought there
by more severely implementing a recent
law that requires such schools to teach
a
common core defined by a
high authority for education
didn't the pope call for a new education
he's a very high authority
i wonder whether the sub-authority must
be in harmony with the
very high authority you see this is
the same okay luther i had also the same
type of language
yes but where we're going with this
we'll quite clearly see
we'll see in a moment he said
school is the republican melting pot
it what makes it possible for us to
protect our children in a complete way
from any religious sign
from religion so there's the difference
there's the difference this is
fascinating
what religion is he against well it
seems like all religion
but why not throw them all into the pot
when you actually are against
one particular second right yeah it is
truly the heart of the space of
secularism
and it is this place where we form
consciences
so that children become free rational
citizens
able to choose their own lives the
school
is therefore our collective treasure it
is what allows us in
our society to build this common thing
that is the republic that's exactly what
martin luther
warned against where
the scriptures are sidelined
this will be the result and here they
will form
the minds so that snow is black
yeah this is a speech he made after the
radical islamic attacks that were in
france but like we've read now and we'll
still read
this pertains to all religion because
france
is a secular country secular state
macron said very clearly that the school
of the republic aims to protect
children from religion
he added that is no doubt one of the
most
radical since the laws of 1882 and those
ensuring
school co-education between boys and
girls
in 1969 from the start of the 2021
school year
school instruction will be made
compulsory for all
from the age of three
that takes away the influence of the
parents
completely homeschooling
will be strictly limited particularly to
health reasons we are therefore changing
our paradigm
and it is vital in the same vein he said
the republic was built around the school
which trains more than individuals it
raises
citizens it shapes free minds
that is why i'm convinced that the
republic will resist
through schools those who want to fight
or divide it
and it is through schools that we will
allow all
our children to access knowledge culture
and republican civic mindedness
and thus to fully become men and
women citizens in other words your mind
must be conformed to the way
the government wants it to be formed
which in turn
is decided by a higher authority
that sits in rome yes so this sounds
like it will be secular
but rome embraces secularism now it's
very useful
to use a radical religion in order to
finally get rid of
all religion yes and to take away
the right of the parent
to instill norms and values
into the minds of their children
now here are lists of some countries
where homeschooling is already
illegal and you see the list is very
long it's germany greece hungary
montenegro netherlands armenia
azerbaijan
georgia i mean the list is very long we
don't have to go through at all and this
is just some of them
and it includes islamic countries like
turkey
and germany as a protestant
christian protestant catholic country so
if we can dump
all religions in there it would be
rather useful now
this book rulers of evil
is a book that everybody i think should
read at some stage it's a very
interesting book
in this book rulers of evil he talks
about
the power of the jesuit order and that
they
are the pinnacle of those who rule over
society in these days
referring to the jesuits he writes
their head would be a supreme general in
the constitutions which
ignazius was writing the superior
general
would be obeyed and reverenced at all
times
as the one who holds the place of christ
our lord
the phrase holds the place of christ
means that the superior general
would share with the pope at a level
unperceived by the general public the
divine
title of vicar of christ
first claimed by galacious
1 on may 13 495
lyola completed constitutions would
repeat
500 times that one is to see
christ in the person of the superior
general so this is how they run and you
must
obey absolutely then he has the jesuit
oath
in there now just for interest sake
the jesuits were to become
the school masters of europe okay yes
and they also ran the council of trent
as they ran the second vatican council
yeah so the second vatican council
on the surface appears to be the
opposite of the council of trent but in
actual fact it's exactly the same thing
just very cleverly devised
so most of the 18-year lifetime of the
council of trent consisted of
two intermissions spanning four and ten
years each
at the beginning of the second
intermission ignazius founded a special
college in rome for german-speaking
jesuits called
the german accused interesting
three years later the piece of augsburg
established the principle
of cuis reggio eus religio
who's the region he's the religion in
other words
when you were in a particular area then
you were protestant if you were in
another area
you were catholic right and the piece of
aussburg was
jesuit pay dirt they could now bring
whole
populations to rome simply by winning
over
a few princes if you get the prince
in the rest if you're living in that
area you fall under what the prince
believes
because the people in those days weren't
allowed to think for themselves
the prince was going to think for them
and the prince was subject
to the church
the fruits of the germanicum were so
successful
that when the council of trent finally
adjourned on december 4
1563 its decrees and canons
conceded nothing to the protestant
reformers
indeed under the spiritual direction of
superior general diego lanez
ignacios had died in 1556
the council denied every protestant
doctrine point by point so this is where
the war
begins and then it gets interesting
my young brother because it says
it was inevitable this is on page 65
it was inevitable that the council of
trent
would establish the jesuits as the
school
masters of europe with
money from royalty and commerce and not
so much
as a panic from the church sure no
so they take it all from the society
which is the way they work to this very
day
so this rich organization
rolling in treasures and gold beyond the
imagination he's always talking about
the poor
every time but exploits the poor in
order to supposedly
help the poor the society built an
extensive system of
schools and colleges no tuition was
charged
but each prospective student was
thoroughly
examined to see if he had aptitude the
society could use
with the founding of the first jesuit
school in
coimbra portugal by the empress youngest
sister katarina
and then it refers to ignatius lyola's
romantic interest
in that particular royalty
the principle jesuit occupation became
teaching by 1556
three-fourths of the society's
membership
were dedicated in 46 jesuit colleges
to learning against learning
to indoctrinating minds with the
learning of
illuminated humanism as opposed to the
learning of scripture
now this is why martin luther
made his speeches and why he said that
the universities and the schools were
cesspools yeah and they had to re
reformation of the education system this
network would expand by 1749 to 669
colleges
176 seminaries 61 houses of study
and 24 universities partly or wholly
under the jesuit direction that's how
they ran
and then the sad sentence many
protestant families
sent their sons to jesuit schools
despite martin luther's early warning
in an appeal to the ruling class which
we just
read about that unless they diligently
train and impress scripture upon their
young
students schools will prove to be
widening
gates of hell now the jesuit curriculum
or ratzio studorium
method of study gave scripture
significant inattention yeah
so the scripture wasn't mentioned at all
in fact
where i taught when scripture was even
mentioned
it was only to ridicule it
and that is what happened to our
universities and i was at a protestant
university
not a catholic university so i wonder
our educated people that have trained at
jesuit institutes
our learned gentlemen that study at
these
cesspools of rationalism
and social equality
how their minds can even grasp
the veracity of scripture they have been
so
poisoned by what they have learned that
it disqualifies
them from being in the pulpit
in many cases unless of course they have
a total transformation yes
and then he has something very
interesting to say
the curriculum of the jesuit colleges
came to be adopted to a great extent
as the basis of the curricula in
european
colleges generally
wrote dr james j watch
dean of fordham university medical
school
moreover according to dr walsh quote
this is on page 66
the founding fathers of our american
republic
that is to say the groups of men who
drew up and signed the declaration of
independence
who were the leaders in the american
revolution
and who formulated the constitution of
the united states
were the majority of them educated in
the colonial colleges
or in corresponding colleges abroad
which have followed almost exactly
the jesuit razzio tutorial
the fact has been missed to a great
extent in our histories of american
education
embedded in the rachel's tutorial he
continues here
where the elements of entertainment
of dramatic productions
composition rhetoric
and eloquence i can add debate to that
these courses interlinked with the
spiritual exercises to
intensify the experientiality of
catholic doctrine over scripture and
protestantism
so that means the spiritual exercises of
fly holla
was implemented in those different areas
to
without people even knowing they they
resulted in a genre of spectacular plays
that won distinction as jesuit theater
now it carries on here and it gets very
interesting
the first jesuit theater was performed
in vienna
in 1555. can you see this is
in the time of the reformation this is a
counter reformation
yes this is the counter reformation
nearly 45 years before the
emergence of shakespeare
it was instantly popular and quickly
spread to other parts of europe between
and 1773 more than 500
jesuit theatricals were staged in the
lower rhine region alone
fascinating jacob biedermann's play
synodoxis a point-by-point
rebuttal of luther's teachings proved
the power of
entertainment to achieve political
reform political reform through jesuit
theater now jesuit theater of course
exists today and is alive and well
and calls itself hollywood which of
course
is the witch's staff
holly is the wood that it is made of
and it is used by witches to cast spells
he writes here and this is very
interesting
he writes here on page 67
england certainly produced the greatest
jesuit
playwright of them all shakespeare
yeah nobody thinks of him as a jesuit
playwright right nope
shakespeare occupies us with the human
process
in a way that subtly marginalizes the
bible
exactly pursuant to the jesuit mission
shakespearean characters do preach
and they preach religion a religion
but it is not the gospel of jesus christ
it is the gnostic illumination of medici
learning that shakespeare preaches the
stuff
of jesuit schools not surprisingly
the secret traditions of templarism
claims shakespeare at least the writer
of his place
to have been a rosicrucian steeped in
medici
learning i can read one more
it's a quote the philosophic ideals
promulgated throughout
shakespearean plays distinctly
demonstrate their author to have been
thoroughly familiar with certain
doctrines and tenants peculiar to
rosicrucianism
in fact the profundity of the
shakespearean production
[Music]
stamps their creator as one of the
illuminati
of the ages who but
a platonist a cabalist or a pythagorean
could have written the tempest macbeth
hamlet or the tragedy of sibylline
who but one deeply versed in paracletion
law
could have conceived a mid-summer
night's dream
so these are some of the thoughts in the
book ruler
of evil just another thought
entertainment also
includes music absolutely
so now when we talk about a new
education
we have to look at all of these points
they want now on a universal scale
to bring in this uniformity of thinking
and as macronut said
let us closely closely
watch what is being taught and let's get
hold
of the young minds did he mention an age
of three
yes from three years ago the catholic
church via the jesuits has a saying
which says give us
a child up to the age of eight
and i have him forever
that's amazing right that's amazing and
it's a spell
it's like a spell now i can i can
testify in my own life
i was an atheist but i was raised
catholic
and i was raised in a system
that i abhorred
and i became an atheist because of the
teaching of hell because my mother was a
protestant everybody knows the story i'm
not going to go into the details now
but it made me an atheist but when the
chips were down
years later the thing i returned to
was catholicism that give me a child
and it is only the scriptures
that set me free could you get you out
of that only the scriptures
and through the scriptures are light
entered
that could dispel that darkness
yeah and from three years old yeah then
that's barely when they
start thinking yes so
now rulers of evil speculated that they
might have been a ghostwriter to
shakespeare right
and many people are wondering who that
could be
and there are some conspiracy theories
out there but
shakespeare is a misnomer he has an
address but he doesn't have an address
he has a birth date but he doesn't have
a birthday
he was married but there are no
certificates there is no proof that the
man
ever existed other than folklore right
if you think of today how many people
write books
with ghost names with ghost names now if
you
if you look at william shakespeare
and you look at another man known as
francis bacon
then there is a very interesting
comparison they were contemporaries they
lived at the same time
or they were one in the same
so let's have a look at a comparison
from wikipedia francis bacon former lord
chancellor
francis bacon first vice count saint
alban
ktpcq also known as the lord
virilam was an english philosopher and
statesman
who served as attorney general and as
lord chancellor of
england his works are credited with
developing the scientific method which
is basically the basis of all university
teaching today
and remained influential throughout the
scientific revolution
according to wikipedia he was born
22nd of january 1561 yorkhouse london
united kingdom he died in 1626.
highgate london united kingdom
influenced by
the scriptures no no
influenced by aristotle plato
niccolo machiavelli roger bacon and more
education trinity college university of
cambridge
university of poitiers so these people
were trained at these universities
and this man was
a philosopher but based on
greek gnostic philosophy william
shakespeare
was an english playwright poet actor
widely regarded as the greatest writer
in the english language and the world's
greatest dramatist
he's often called english national poet
and the bard of avon he was born
1564. look over here
born 1561.
stratford-upon-avon died 1616.
this one 16 26 there are many that
believe
that this rosicrucian francis bacon
steeped in medici learning as we
read in rulers of evil and
knowledgeable in the cabal and
gnosticism
was a very probable candidate
as being the ghost writer for the
shakespearean plays
but be that as it may that is just
speculation
but this is the education yeah that the
world cherishes
so martin we have
now compared what martin luther said
with what the jesuits did to education
in the world
the world has become a world of chaos
a world of violence
and as the authors that we have studied
have claimed
cesspools of hell yeah
and now they are talking about a new
education
one that will bring everybody into line
with a particular way of thinking
individualism must go
a group collective paradigm
must come into play and for that they
have coined a new buzzword
which is called solidarity solidarity
so i think we should
start a second episode where we further
discuss
how this will develop because this is
such an important issue yeah and it's
going somewhere
and where does it go yeah maybe
unexpected for some but
this re-education like you've mentioned
now it's not only in
learning it's in entertainment
in all of these all of these issues the
groundwork has been laid
the pillars of protestantism have been
brought down
the last vestige of protestant teaching
lies on the streets
covered in blood and now it is time
to bring in a new education that sweeps
away
all religion as we have seen and
brings in that illuminated
gnostic teaching that is at the heart of
jesuit teaching
we have a jesuit pope we have
a jesuit school system in the world
and the world is ready for a new
education
we've seen that we've got from both
sides
of the political spectrum
a push towards catholicism as well
correct
but you know what the bible has an
interesting verse
and the lord jesus says woe
to those it were better that a millstone
be tied round their necks than that they
should make one of the least of these
my little ones stumble
this is a confrontation
with the god of the universe that will
culminate
in the final events on this planet
and for humanity this is the choice
that people will have to make and we
will deal with that
in part two let's pray
heavenly father we do indeed
need a new education
but as solomon said there is nothing new
under the sun what has been
will be and as martin luther called for
an education
where the word of god was central
so i pray that your people will realize
that they have to give their children
a new education with a renewed
emphasis on those issues which lead to
eternal life
grant us wisdom in a time of
great trouble and adversity
may the god of all wisdom and the god of
all true education be with us
as we approach the climax of your
earth's history i pray in jesus name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe to our channel
click here to get notifications click on
the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again